foreign
let's move on to obsolete objects from
Alabama I'm going to skip the first one
and go straight to the second one today
Bex and I saw this we were driving this
morning down uh the 101 toward L.A and
we saw these sunglasses on a woman next
to us this is an approximate pair of
sunglasses if you're watching the video
version you'll see them above me I have
a thing for big stupid sunglasses
they're just big stupid glasses in
general so a particular Kink of mine
and uh and Bex was saying like I like
the way sunglasses look and I even like
the functionality of them but I think
they've become obsolete in my life so
this subject or this topic when we do
obsolete objects as a segment what we're
really talking about things that once
added value to our lives but maybe our
lives will be fine or even better
without these objects which by the way
you can send us your obsolete objects
podcast at the minimalists.com oh you
can also send us your sucky
advertisements your checkout line wisdom
you're a Masset or trash your questions
should you keep something should you let
it go we'll let you know on a future
podcast episode just send it to podcast
at the minimalists.com but Bex we were
driving and you said
sunglasses I feel like I used to like
them but they trick our bodies yeah I
mean I still like them I like them from
a design point I like them from an
aesthetic Point like
but I I just don't like wearing them
anymore because they do trick our bodies
they they filter out certain you know
wavelengths of light that our bodies
really need in order to tell what time
of day it is and turns out that's
actually really important for our health
um circadian biology circadian rhythm
like it just it makes a big difference
being exposed to the full spectrum of of
light at any given point in the day
versus a highly filtered one and granted
like you know the example of driving
this morning in the car
like in a car as long as like your
windows are up and you don't have a
convertible or something
um you're still not getting the full
spectrum of light it's not like you're
outside where you would be getting the
full spectrum of light so driving is one
of those examples where it's like yeah
it's probably not making that big of a
difference to have sunglasses on versus
not but when you're actually outside
um it does make a big difference yeah so
I've just kind of been like well yeah
they look cool
and yes it's it's nice sometimes
um to to have a pair of glasses
especially when you're driving to reduce
glare and eye fatigue and stuff but
feels like an obsolete item at this
point despite them being very attractive
sometimes and often it's difficult
especially at first because you're so
used you've been trained to wear them
especially you're going to the beach and
it's so sunny out but that's when you
want to be exposed to the full spectrum
of like I'm not saying stare at the sun
obviously no but what I'm saying is that
it makes sense to go without because of
your circadian rhythm for your own
health yeah yeah and you so what you'll
find generally speaking is if you've
been wearing sunglasses outside most of
the time or all the time that there's a
an adjustment period where your eyes are
they're pretty unhealthy frankly they
don't react the same way as they're
designed to react to the bright full
sunlight and so there's a I don't know
what the window of of acclimation is but
there's a period of time in which it's
just going to feel bright and
overwhelming and maybe you wear a hat or
you know some other sort of
mitigation strategy where you're out for
a few minutes and then you go back
inside and then you're out for a few
minutes later and you go back inside but
um
yeah I don't even notice it now I never
wear sunglasses and I don't squint it
doesn't hurt my eyes every now and then
like when I'm on a boat like on the
water and the Sun is really intense like
I'll be a little squinty but it's pretty
rare
I usually wear a hat but other than that
that's the that's the only accommodation
I've never really worn sunglasses
yeah I have I wear glasses most of the
time so I I don't want to layer over
there so I feel a lot better hearing
that yeah I don't feel like I'm behind
because I'm like oh no the California
heat I should wear sunglasses and a hat
yeah yeah unfortunately like Vision
classes filtered not all of the same
things but it's not quite it's kind of
like a car window yeah it's still filter
stuff but did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free